buenas noches buenas tardes para ustedes
gracias por invitarme bueno el enfoque
del conflicto ha tomado a ucrania como
actor central de la controversia cuando
acaso deberíamos preguntarnos si es que
ucrania es realmente el actor central yo
lo que veo en un plano amplio y poco
discutido es aun vladimir putin que
viene a ser una suerte de agente
disruptivo que pretende refutar corregir
en beneficio de moscú la derrota
geopolítica que significó la caída de la
unión soviética y por otro lado tenemos
a un joe biden reaccionando muy
proactivamente porque precisamente se
niega a negociar o arriesgar lo que es
para el inobjetable las ventajas
obtenidas en el plano de la geopolítica
europea por los eeuu a raíz de su
triunfo en la guerra fría
ahora por otro lado están los ejercicios
de rusia con misiles que iniciaron hoy
que el mensaje enviar esto justo cuando
eeuu dice que rusia ya está lista para
atacar
pienso que el mensaje es claro y tiene
que ver con que a pesar de toda la
retórica pro soberanía pro integridad
territorial que en numerosos estados
europeos además de los estados unidos
han practicado a favor de ucrania rusia
le está diciendo al mundo que después de
todo es una potencia nuclear a la que se
debe tomar muy en serio y
fundamentalmente deben tomarse muy en
serio sus preocupaciones e intereses
políticos actuales dado que rusia la
rusia de putin de la que putin se
jactara probablemente como su legado
principal es muy distinta de la rusia
debilitada y postrada de los años 90 y
boris jaisingh
y ya ya ha pasado por ejemplo más de una
semana desde que se advirtió el ataque
inminente autrán ya que tan probable es
que suceda a estas alturas
es probable que suceda según mi opinión
si es que no se logra
[Música]
comentar realmente convertir con una
mayor honestidad la controversia que no
se está atacando y la controversia
vincula fundamentalmente a los eeuu y a
rusia debería convocarse una cumbre
entre ambos estados para que no sé si
discuten y discutan o reformen pero que
tomen en consideración las posturas de
uno y otro en el marco de este mundo
geopolítico que ya no es el mismo de los
años 90 mientras eso no suceda es
probable que rusia intente por otros
medios hacerse respetar y proteger sus
recobrados intereses geopolíticos